So we have seen that in cycle 13 this instruction commits.
It commits by depositing the value of four into register R2.
Looking at the ROB entry for R2 to see whether it points to it, and
it does. And thus we make the entry in the RAT point to the register file, and
freeing the ROB entry. Now we will consider what happens in cycle 14.
This instruction would write the result in cycle 16. This instruction is an add,
it executes in 13 and writes the result in 14.
The question for you is, does the RAT,
any entry change? So for example, if you believe that the RAT entry for
R1 is going to change, the write R1 here. So which RAT entry
changes as the result of writing this value for ROB6 instruction?